spider-man homecoming has arrived and
it's far more tangled in the massive web
of the Marvel Cinematic Universe than
anyone ever expected with references to
over 50 years of Marvel Comics if the
average spider can lay anywhere between
ten and fifteen hundred eggs just how
many Easter eggs did homecoming leave
behind and if your spidey sense is
tingling that's only because there are
spoilers ahead damage control so who
cleans up after superheroes and their
arch villains have their mega
destructive throw downs all over the
globe in the comics that job goes to
damage control a government agency
that's been around since 1988
Marvel has been kicking around the idea
of a damage control sitcom since 2015
but the project never really made it off
the ground so while we may never see a
Marvel sitcom a la DC failed powerless
damage control has officially made it
into continuity and Adrian Toomes is not
happy Betty Brant Peter Parker school
has its own TV news program starring
none other than Marvel mainstay Betty
Brant but he first appeared in the
amazing spider-man number four way back
in 1963 as newspaper moguls j jonah
Jameson secretary eventually she becomes
a pretty successful investigative
reporter and even has a fling with the
Hobgoblin she plays a pretty big part in
spider-man's life and a version of her
even appeared in Tobey Maguire's
spider-man so it's not unlikely that
she'll figure into the future in one way
or another spider signal we saw it in
Civil War's post-credit scene but we see
it again when Peter's tinkering with his
suits devices in homecoming comic fans
all felt a weird tingle when Peter
briefly projected a spider-man logo onto
the wall bringing back comic memories of
spider-man's most hilariously useless
device contrary to Batman's awesome fat
signal which summons the Dark Knight
from great distances
spider-man spider signal doesn't do much
more than announces arrival to criminals
and occasionally acts at the flashlight
not every idea from the early days of
spider-man was a good one those armpit
webs on the other hand will always be
pure comic-book gold summon to sinister
6 the appearance of Adrian Toomes aka
vulture
it definitely isn't an easter egg but it
probably takes a real comic fan to spot
some of society's other legendary foes
while the sinister six has taken many
forms over the years the elderly vulture
has usually been a core member also
pretty prominent in homecoming is
shocker who seems to be whoever's
wearing an alien tech enhanced glove but
the reference to the comics shocker goes
to fold when those same guys are seen
wearing the same distinctive yellow
quilted fabric that the comic villain
wears
[Music]
you'll also find Mac Gargan aka a
scorpion played by Michael mando in
contrast to homecomings Gargan comic
book Gargan started out as an
investigative reporter whose life is
messed up by the experimental process
that gives him a giant's mechanical
scorpion tail if there was any doubt
about these two Guardians being related
there's also that giant scorpion tattoo
on big screen gargons neck - we also get
a whole lot of Hobgoblin and sorry to
say it's Peter Parker's biggest fan and
best friend Ned while his full name is
never given nez last name has been given
as leaves in a few different
publications
Ned Leeds becomes one of at least seven
different hobgoblins after being
brainwashed by the original Hobgoblin
Roderick Kingsley to take his place
let's say that things don't end well the
howling commando legacy if you think
you're seeing a familiar face at Peter
Parker's school it's because after
Kenneth Choi is playing his own grandson
way back in Captain America the First
Avenger Troy played Jim Morita a member
of caps Howlin commandoes a legendary
group of Marvel Comics soldiers
originally operating under Nick Fury joy
returned in homecoming to play principal
Morita
a guy obviously very proud of his
grandpa given the photo of Jim that can
be spotted in his office Morita Junior
Junior's love of history also possibly
explains his affection for those
terrible Captain America instructional
videos and speaking of cameos and photos
around the school The Incredible Hulk
himself Bruce Banner appears in one of
the many posters of great scientists
featured around the science class
and who's that on the school mural
Howard Stark himself
spider-man 2.0 fans of Donald Glover
know that he kind of campaigned to play
spider-man in a big-screen adaptation of
the comic books and then somebody put a
big picture of me in the comments below
to play spider-man
he's nerdy his interest in the role
prompted spider scribe Brian Michael
Bendis to create a new spider-man
inspired by Glover named Miles Morales
and while Glover never made it to the
big screen as Spidey he did voice the
character of Miles Morales on the
ultimate spider-man animated series in
2015 Glover returned to the Spidey
verson homecoming as Aaron Davis a
career criminal with the alias of
Prowler according to spider-man files
sure Marvel's main Prowler is some guy
named Hobie but in the Ultimate Universe
it's a guy named Aaron Davis his nephew
a guy named Miles Morales the very same
nephew that Prowler refers to during his
parking garage confrontation with
spider-man and if that wasn't
confirmation enough check out his
license plates
you see sm0 one which is short for
Ultimate Comics spider-man number one
Karen one spider-man has access to his
suits full capabilities he's treated to
a very jarvis like computer which is
able to cater to his every need which he
names Karen Avengers fans know that
within the MCU Jarvis is Tony Stark's
personal computer which then merged with
a robot body becoming vision along the
way Jarvis was always played by Paul
Bettany
even as the infinity stone wielding
vision in real life that knee is married
to Jennifer Connelly who plays the voice
of Karen and homecoming
keeping the pair of companion computer
programs as close as the people who
actually play them true to the page one
of Spidey's most memorable scenes came
in amazing spider-man number 33 the
comics cover spells out Spidey's perils
pretty clearly and it's nearly identical
to the scene in homecoming when vulture
causes the roof to cave in on Parker for
five pages spider-man struggles under
wet rubble thinking of his
responsibilities as the wall crawler and
that gives him the strength to set
himself free it's pretty much comic book
perfect credits do blink and you'll miss
it among the countless Skrulls of
graffiti decorating Peter Parker's new
York City but eagle-eyed viewers have
spotted the word vaguely emblazoned amid
the colorful chaos Mark Bagley is noted
in the Marvel Comics universe for being
a huge contributor to spider-man
co-creating the villain carnage and
illustrating Venom's early turn as an
antihero in the venom lethal protector
miniseries so his quick mention is no
mistake and casual comic fans might be
left wondering why Jack Kirby is given
any credit at all for spider-man during
the film's credit sequence since Spidey
is one of the few 1960s comic characters
that Kirby was never really associated
with comics history reveals that Kirby
enly sat down together to come up with
spider-man and Kirby even drew the first
batch of pages for the hero using his
own designs before Lee rejected the
concept and changed it a bit to fit his
own vision
Kirby ended up penciling just the covers
of Spidey's debut in amazing fantasy
number 15 as well as amazing spider-man
number 1 before moving on to other
projects but his impact on spider-man
being acknowledged by Marvel is a pretty
big deal thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our YouTube
channel let's check out all this cool
stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]